The Joe Rogan experience.
Is back to the subject of a capitalism, capitalism,
and Marxism and socialism this, uh,
right now we're in a wave of this, right. It's become more popular now. Uh,
I would say over the last, particularly during the Trump administrations,
the concept of socialism, at least it's become more,
more publicly discussed then, uh, anytime that I can remember in my life,
why do you think that is?
I think it's because the generation that's coming up is, I mean,
you have to understand the academic community is,
is I always say the intellectuals have always been the enemy of
business, uh, enemy of certainly the enemy of capitalism.
And, but why is that? I think because in a,
in a market society, uh, which has been rare in history,
we haven't mostly had market societies,
but they're not very important in a market society. Uh,
the intellectuals aren't very important, generally, not as important to know.
Are they the ones that inspire the minds of the people that create in and
maybe innovate in the end.
They don't have the same social status that the entrepreneurs have, uh,
an Elon Musk or Steve jobs or Jeff Bezos.
I think it's an.
Ego issue. The social status.
Issue. Think about it this way. If you're you're, you're going to school. Okay.
And the people that end up teaching the universities were always the smartest
kids in the school generally. And they, and they did well in school. I mean,
smart in terms of doing well in school and they go on to college and then they,
they, they go and get a PhD and then they, they,
that's all they've known as school. That's, that's been their universe, right.
And they excelled at it and they were smarter than the other kids in school.
And now these other kids, they,
they go to college and they get a degree in business and they're in a fraternity
and they make a lot of friends and relationships and I think,
and they make more money than the intellectuals do.
And that seems like that's completely unfair.
It's an unjust world that this less smart people are making more money than
the smart people do. And they have more status in the society. And I think,
I think that's under,
under underlying it is a resentment or an envy of a society that
doesn't judge them to be as important as they judge themselves.
That's interesting, but I think it's a very flawed perspective.
And first of all, the term smart is a weird term.
I said, smart. In terms of school,
I didn't say in terms of street smart or ability to do things,
to connect with people, uh, there's emotional intelligence.
I'm merely saying they're good at taking tests, writing papers, uh,
abstracting thoughts, essentially.
Yeah, but this is what I'm saying. That just the term smart,
it's almost like the promise. That's like a blanket term, right?
It's like drugs, you know,
like applies to a bunch of different things that don't necessarily seem to be
related.
But the people that are interested in that pursue
the fact that they can't understand that there's an intact like Elon
Musk is a great example. If you don't think Elon Musk is intelligent,
you're either did not. You're in, you're not very.
Intelligent yourself. You don't think Elon Musk is intelligent.
You're delusional or you're a liar or you're in denial, right.
It's one of those things, there's something wrong with the way you think. Well,
he's clearly intelligent,
but there's people that call him a fool and that like the guys running like four
different businesses simultaneously, they're all successful.
And he's innovating with, when it comes to space,
travel in a way that you would assume that someone has to dedicate most of their
life, just singularly to that task,
to be able to figure out past NASA how to shoot a rocket up into space and have
it land. Right. And then reuse it. No,
one's been able to do that besides him or up until he did it. And I think, uh,
Jeff Bezos's company is doing the same thing. Yeah.
Um, blue origin. Yeah. They're,
they're obviously two of the great entrepreneurs of this particular area.
But I don't think Jeff Bezos is actually engineering these things.
But if you think about it, the intellectuals have always disliked business.
They've always discriminated against the merchant classes. The Jews in the West,
Chinese in the East,
there's really been no historical period where intellectuals praised business,
maybe a little bit around the time of Adam Smith up until probably
Ricardo and Malthus wrote in the early 19th century.
That is for the most part business, people have been seen. They're disruptive.
They change things. They upset the status quo there. They innovate. Well,
a lot of people don't like innovations, it's threatening.
It changes a change of social status.
It changes wealth relationships, uh,
that it's almost like, uh,
capitalism is like a genie that got out of the bottle.
And they're trying very hard to stuff the genie back in the bottle as much as
they can. And I think if you think about it that way, you'll understand.
We're never going to win the intellectuals over. I mean,
I speak in universities all the time and the students I'm an entrepreneur.
I self-identify that way. Students love. When I talk about conscious capitalism,
I say, you can do good and you can do well. There's no contradiction here.
You're not, you're the good guys here. You're not the bad guys,
people about this. I do. I did not. I've debated a number of socialists. And.
What, what is their primary argument?
Their primary argument is, is that business is greedy and selfish.
And it's about motivations. That, that, that,
that business people have the wrong motivations.
And a lot of ways conscious capitalism is an answer to that.
It's a complete answer to that because in the book and in conscious leadership
as well, we're basically arguing that business.
Isn't primarily about maximizing profits.
Business is primarily about creating value for other people and through creating
value for other people, you do make a profit,
but it's the value creation that comes first.
The profits come second in exchange, right? And it's almost,
if you are creating value,
then you are profitable and then you can reinvest those profits and you,
and you have this upwards spiral. Um,
so that's that business has this potential for higher purpose.
It's not primarily about greed. Greed is found in human nature. Joe,
it's not just found in business people. There are plenty of greedy,
governmental officials, plenty of greedy politicians, greedy lawyers,
greed is endemic to the human nature business. People either have no more,
no less than it. It's just part of who we are.
Has anyone ever laid it out in a way that's very compelling?
Like when you have these debates with socialists and someone,
has anyone ever laid it out in a way where they have a point where you see their
points.
You always,
the best way to do a debate is completely understand the other side's position
and understand it as good or better than they understand it.
And so I've read widely in socialistic literature.
I think I do understand it. It's, it's, it's a type of utopianism. It's, uh,
it's an attempt to change human nature. If we would all be,
if we would all love each other. And if we'd all share equally, uh,
then the world would be a better place. And Hey, guess what?
It probably would be if, if we were naturally that way,
but we're not naturally that way. We,
we look first generally for ourselves and our own families. And then our,
and our growing circle of relationships that we develop. We want, we don't,
it's not natural to, it's natural to want your own children to have advantages.
That's, that's just human nature to want your children to flourish because you,
you raise them. You love them. And somehow, or another to say,
that's unfair is cutting against human nature.
People are always going to look for, for advantages or privileges,
so to speak for their children.
People don't like when people have advantages and have, and have victories,
because then someone has to lose. And when someone loses,
they equate that someone losing with a bad feeling with that person being
victimized, like there's some.
Sorry, here's the big idea we talk about in conscious leadership,
we have a chapter called find win, win, win solutions.
The metaphors that we use to think about society tend to be very
binary,
good versus evil light versus darkness win versus
lose. And so they tend to think of business as a win lose game.
Somebody wins and somebody else's losing,
but the beauty of capitalism is it's a win-win win game. It's an infinite game.
It's a game because the customers are winning or they wouldn't trade.
The employees are winning how the customer is winning.
They're getting products and services at a, at a,
an and there's competition to make those services and products better.
Uh, the employees are winning because they have jobs and opportunities to grow.
Benefits are paid and they do that voluntarily,
not forced to work for any particular company.
They do it because they think it's in their best interest.
When for the employees, the suppliers who are trading with the business,
they're winning as well, or they wouldn't make the exchanges.
Investors are winning or they wouldn't make the investments.
And the larger society is winning because business is the engine that creates
all the money that goes into nonprofits and governments without business,
there is no government and there is no,
and there is no nonprofit sector because those are ultimately supplied through
what business creates. So businesses, a win, win, win game.
All of these tech holders are winning and that's why capitalism lifts society up
socialism is an attempt to reverse that back to a win lose game.
And that's why it always fails. And that's why capital.
That was an attempt to bring it back to win, lose game. In what way?
It, it, it, th the ones that are winning, so to speak the business,
people are clamped down. So they're not allowed to win. It's like,
we're going to take your success and we're going to redistribute it. So that is,
again, you said earlier on incentives matter,
but we're going to take away the incentives for business to really flourish and
succeed. They should do it from altruistic reasons.
And we may do some things for altruistic reasons,
but you cannot build a society around it.
When you're talking about win-win win. This is a very,
in many ways it's I see what you're saying,
but there are things that are negative that are associated with
profit and innovation and particularly expanding industry, right?
Particularly environmental impacts. Like when you talk,
when you say win-win win, like there's,
there's very rarely when you're,
especially when you're dealing with creating and designing and building
things, you've got a negative impact in some way,
environmentally too.
Two points. Um, first of all, historically, socialism has been far worse,
worst polluter than in capitalist countries. Well,
if you just look at the environmental destruction that the Soviet union left
behind it, it was a contender.
Wait disaster. Right. But that's this, this is socialism done wrong, John,
we're going to do it right here. Has.
Done it. Right, Joe. No, one's done it.
Right. But the Soviet union is a bad example.
Yeah.
But all of Eastern Europe where there there's no incentive to protect the common
good in socialism. And they don't.
When the government has a monopoly of all decision and power making,
they don't tend to look out for the environment. That's one of the myths.
Can wait agency from people and you,
you take away their desire to improve and do better.
And without incentive, people just don't perform the same way.
But the beautiful thing about business,
let's concede a partial truth to what you said, that there will be
unintended negative consequences, as you say, environmentally. Well,
that's why you have to regulate business to a certain extent.
That's why you have to make people responsible for their environmental
pollutants and because Bennett business innovates and has an incentive to
innovate, um,
business can innovate and create solutions to those environmental problems.
Okay. Let me stop you there for a second. When you say,
make people responsible for their environmental pollutants, then we're,
we're going to have to deal with another aspect of capitalism. And that's the,
the fact the special interest groups and lobbyists have on politicians because
they create laws that shield these big businesses from consequences,
from these negative actions.
So by saying that they have to clean up their problem,
the only way that's ever going to happen is if they're not protected,
if they don't use that influence and money. Totally agree.
So this is where I think a lot of people have a valid argument
against capitalism. Capitalism is kind of over our, our, our,
our system of government in a way,
because money has gotten so deeply involved with super PACS and
lobbyists.
And there's so much money involved that it changes the way
we govern things.
Is that a flaw of capitalism or is that a flaw of government?
I think it's a flaw of government,
but that government has been influenced by capitalism,
by capitalism's desire for universal growth, for constant growth.
The sad truth is that humanity is not perfectible.
We can never create the perfect system and the attempt to create the perfect
system. The perfect saying to me, the good capitalism is not perfect.
It does not because human choices and what people want various people
to, uh,
capitalism will sell cigarettes to people because that's what people want.
It gives them pleasure, but it's bad for their health, but they're, they're,
they're giving people what they want. It's the same thing in,
in any type of externality. That's not,
that's not deliberately done to harm the society. It's sort of a by-product.
This is why win-win win. Doesn't really work. It's not really, win-win win.
It's win most of the time,
but with some negative consequences that are better than the alternative, right?
But what you strive for is to,
is to take those externalities or those negative consequences and try
to through good government to, to minimize them or less than them.
I'll give you an example. So you used to live in LA. Well,
when I went to LA back in the early eighties,
it was like going to new Delhi today.
I couldn't see my lungs hurt less than 24 hours,
but through good regulations,
the error in LA is a fraction as polluted as it was 40 years
ago, we have been able to clean it up.
That is an example of how you can take the worst impacts of industrialization
and ameliorate. Them are less than.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st is December 1st.
They're going to be available everywhere, but after December 1st,
they will only be available on Spotify, but they will be free.
That includes the video. The video will also be there. It'll also be free.
That's all we're asking. Go download Spotify, Bubba.